[Music]
a best friend who's the definition of
fabulous a posh mother-in-law who's a
fashion icon you don't get any better
than that and a husband who loves the
way she looks in anything first
time where we hung out at Halloween I
would like you to wear this again are
you crazy
catsuit oh yeah do you want me to wear
that Terry Knox dinner date yeah no no
Nicola Peltz Beckham is living a dream
life and her Circle could be growing we
really do want a big family Nicola
dazzles in a silver mini dress on the
cover of Cosmopolitan and says she in
Brooklyn have babies on the brain but we
need a house first especially because we
have so many puppies I've always wanted
to be a young dad I could have like 10.
what do you make of that number that is
really sweet
um well I grew up in a family I've I've
seven siblings
so I think he he loves being with my
family and there's the friends who
become family like Selena Gomez Nicola
praises the actress calling her a soul
sister quote I love her so much she's
truly one of the most amazing people
I've ever met in my whole life you know
my personal life and my family and my
friends I'm just I'm in a really happy
place it's been good in the mag out
March 28th Nicola also sets the record
straight about her relationship with
Brooklyn's mom Victoria Beckham I'm a
ghost girl I I really love women their
rumored Feud's been a Hot Topic ever
since Nicola and Brooklyn got together
picking up steam when Nicola chose a
Valentino wedding dress for her eye dues
instead of the one made by Victoria I
just think people should feel
comfortable but Nicholas saying pish
posh to all of that quote there's no
Feud she says no one ever wants to write
the nice things it's really weird
actually whether it's my life or someone
else's that said the headlines keep
coming as legal filings leak out in a
court battle between Nicholas family and
her fired wedding planner with claims of
fighting between the two families
filling up the tabloids obviously like
it's not the best thing to see people
writing not the nicest of things but you
know we have each other we have each
other's back more than anything so I
think we've just both learned to don't
listen to that
foreign